I realize before I froze my eggs there
was just this constant inner monologue
that was like is this the guy you're
gonna be with if not you have to move on
to someone else and I felt like I had to
accomplish all my professional goals by
the time I was like 35 and it was just
in the back of my mind all the time like
I'd be in traffic and I believe you guys
let's go I'm rotting from the inside
we got a bow okay uterus is molding I
feel like you guys will never understand
that pressure because you guys don't
have that clock guys can have kids as
late as they want
Clint Eastwood had a kid at like 70
years old Robert De Niro had won at like
68 which is so weird to me the idea of
having a kid it's 68 years old that's
like being like I really want a kid but
only for like ten years
and I want to be death for most of it
that's I'm so glad I did it it took all
this pressure off like I used to be the
stress case now I'm just chilling man
so easy like my agent calls me up he's
like where's that script I'm like I
don't know I'm high as call Sarah
Silverman or some man cuz I'm
watching Game of Thrones again today hey
camera I thank you you freeze your eggs
for a couple of reasons if you want to
postpone having kids also if you want to
get a surrogate at some point which I'm
kind of obsessed with the idea of
getting a surrogate it's like you hire a
woman to carry your kid for you which I
really want to do at some point but I
feel kind of guilty about that idea
because when you get a surrogate you're
essentially like asking another woman to
do your dirty work for you it's like
worse than a guy getting a hooker
because when you get a hooker you guys
just want to use a woman's body for an
hour I want to use it for nine months
and totally wreck it I'm literally gonna
destroy that
not nice I just feel like I would like
my kids so much more if I didn't carry
my kid it makes sense like I totally
support those toddler and t-ara moms I
think those kids should work I think
they should have to tap dance to pay for
all the damage they did to those poor
women although I feel like if you have a
surrogate have your kid you can't
control the kid as well you know like
the way my mom used to guilt me into
doing things she'd be like I carried you
for nine months
I'd be like yeah that's a good point but
if like I had a surrogate what am I
gonna say I'm gonna be like I had to
drive 10 minutes to pick you up traffic
was a nightmare yeah it's not as good
when you freeze your eggs the doctor
asks you if you want to get a donor like
a sperm donor because if you want to
freeze embryos you know like basically
if you freeze an embryo that means a
sperm fertilizes the egg and I was like
I don't have any sperm available in my
house at the moment
so he's like maybe you should get a
donor and he wasn't really ready for
that but I got super obsessed with the
kind of person who would become a sperm
donor so I went online and I was like on
the donor site you'd think that sperm
donors for complete losers not true in
order to be a sperm donor you have to be
at least five eight I was like I'm sorry
what shallow was 45 years old not
married no options goes into the sperm
bank is like oh five seven never mind
I'm gonna get on FarmersOnly and take my
chances that weirdo
[Applause]
and an ordinary ruler you have to have
at least four years of college I was
like I don't want my sperm donor to have
four years of college because if you
have four years of college and you're
jerking off into a cup for $100 you're a
drug addict and if you don't have four
years of college and you're jerking off
into a cup for $100 you're an
entrepreneur and I like your hustle